security is expected to be very tight at
to public New Year's Eve celebrations
around the world in the u.s. heavily
armed police and counterterrorism
officers will be protecting revelers on
the ground and from rooftops in many
cities following the terror attacks
earlier this year in New York and the
mass shooting in Las Vegas a similar
story is playing out in Europe following
a series of terror attacks targeting
large gatherings in Britain and France
this year Barry Petersen is in London
with the latest Barry good morning the
concern about terrorism has not dampened
enthusiasm here in London where a
hundred thousand people have bought
tickets to a sold-out fireworks display
to be held here on the banks of the
Thames London was hard-hit this year in
March a terrorist drove down Westminster
Bridge hitting pedestrians then stabbed
a police officer the terrorist and five
others died in June through terror stage
a similar vehicle attack on London
Bridge eight died and the three
terrorists were shot to death but as the
city gets ready for tomorrow night's
events London Police say they are ready
Nick Allsworth is spokesperson for the
Metropolitan Police Service we are
maintaining a proportionate response to
what we see the threat to be Paris the
city of lights is dressed up for the
holiday but France is also on edge after
a series of attacks over the last three
years that have killed some 230 people
tourists are now accustomed to armed
guards at popular attractions and there
will be a lot more Sunday night the
city's police chief outlined the show of
force never put off the measure will be
based on a strong mobilization he said
adding the 10,000 police and first
responders will be on duty police in
Berlin are bracing for hundreds of
thousands out on what's called the party
mile crowds are a challenge to police
says John Millard New York's Deputy
Commissioner for intelligence and
terrorism what you're looking for is to
is to do what people expect but also do
what your adversary might not expect the
idea is
to have enough of a visual deterrent so
people look at this and say it's a hard
target but the other idea is to have
enough tools in place so if anything
happens you reduce that time and you
reduce that impact to the bare minimum
in London there will be security you can
see like armed police on these barriers
against any vehicles and security you
cannot see the city has thousands of
cameras and there will be undercover
police mingling with the crowds to
protect any bystanders and attack any
terrorists Barry Petersen in London
thank you